au mois de février au mois de mars
c'était terrible parce qu'on n'avait pas
encore une aussi grande portion de la
population vaccinée
maintenant il ya moins
d'hospitalisations il ya moins de quatre
graves mais quand même il ya des
hospitalisations il ya des personnes aux
soins intensifs
donc c'était tout à fait il fallait s'y
attendre
la vaccination reste très bien au
portugal
moi même j'ai déjà les deux doses de
vaccin je suis entièrement vacciner j'ai
mon certificat maintenance avancée par
tranche d'âge
donc ils vont attaquer à partir de 35
ans je crois ils on voit les visages de
après de baisser et peut-être les
adolescents inscrits plus tard c'est
envisagé d'évacuer aussi dans des cas de
contamination qui augmente en plein euro
de football
la compétition sportive at elle sa part
de responsabilité
l'onu demande en tout cas au pays hôte
d'assurer un meilleur suivi de la
circulation des spectateurs y compris
avant leur arrivée et après leur départ
du stade quand un mot clark un brin
douce et des stades bondés des
supporters venus de toute l'europe des
bars et fan zone plein à craquer le coc
vide 19 au second plan pour les fans de
ballon rond
alors que le nombre de nouveaux cas
hebdomadaires a augmenté pour la
première fois en dix semaines l'euro de
football apparaît comme un vecteur
probable de propagation du variant delta
en europe
inquiète l'organisation mondiale de la
santé espère que la compétition n'a pas
joué un rôle de super propagateur ce
jeudi l' oms a également appelé à
assurer un meilleur suivi des supporters
présents dans les stades
nous devons regarder bien au delà des
stades eux mêmes ce que nous devons
examiner c'est ce qui se passe autour de
ce stade comment les gens s'y rendent
ainsi se déplace-t-il dans de grands
convois de bus bondés principe des
mesures individuelles lorsqu'ils le font
que se passe-t-il après les matchs
lorsque les gens quittent les stades
cette déclaration fait écho aux
nombreuses contaminations recensés parmi
les supporters à leur retour dans leur
pays d'origine selon les autorités
sanitaires 2000 écossais ont ainsi été
testés positifs après avoir assisté à la
rencontre angleterre écosse le 18 juin
autre exemple plus de 300 fans
finlandais sont repartis de saint
pétersbourg positif au coït 19 après la
rencontre russie finlande
l'augmentation du nombre de nouvelles
infections s'explique en grande partie
par les infections constaté lors du
championnat d'europe de football
au cours des semaines précédentes au
moins 4500 finlandais se sont rendus au
championnat d'europe de football à saint
pétersbourg en russie
les personnes revenant de la compétition
ont été identifiés le 30 juin à travers
386 résultats de tests positifs et 50
suivi d'infection la russie comme
l'angleterre connaît actuellement une
explosion du nombre d'infections après
des critiques émanant du ministre de
l'intérieur allemand concernant la
politique des jauges de spectateurs dans
le stade de wembley à londres
c'est au tour de la chancelière
allemande angela merkel en visite au
royaume uni de s'inquiéter de ces fortes
affluences en allemagne nous avons
décidé que moins de spectateurs auraient
assisté au match au satde unique
mais bien sûr le gouvernement
britannique prend ses propres décisions
mais je suis très préoccupé samedi quand
à savoir que c'est une bonne chose et si
cela ne fait pas un peu trop
une crainte balayée d'un revers de main
par le premier ministre britannique
la position est très claire on
à savoir que nous avons certains
événements que nous pouvons organiser de
manière très prudente et contrôlés en
testant tous ceux qui s'y rendent et le
point crucial est que comme je les dis
plutôt ici au royaume uni
nous avons maintenant construire un mur
considérable d'immunité contre la
maladie grâce à notre programme de
vaccination il égale sa disparaît le
gouvernement britannique après
concertation avec l'uefa a pris la
décision d'augmenter les jauges de
remplissage pour les demi finales et la
finale
soixante mille personnes devrait ainsi
assister à ces trois rencontres
pour rappel le variant delta
représentent plus de 90% des nouvelles
infections au royaume uni reste à voir
désormais durant les prochaines semaines
si cet euro 2021 sera considérée comme
une réussite ou un fiasco sanitaire le
vario delta présent dans 85 pays dont la
russie confrontée à une nouvelle vague
épidémique meurtrière pour le quatrième
jour consécutif le pays vient
d'enregistrer un record de décès en 24
heures 6 179 morts la correspondance à
moscou deux vérins goffman il n'est pas
question de confinement déclaré le porte
parole du kremlin dmitri peskov
il a appelé la population russe à se
faire vacciner le plus vite possible
afin d'éviter justement le retour aux
restrictions les plus drastiques et côté
personne ne veut de confinement il n'est
pas question de confinement voilà
pourquoi pour qu'il n'en soit pas
question il faut se faire vacciner
nous devons tous nous faire vacciner le
plus vite possible
moi ce qu en même temps subi une
augmentation explosive des cas de
coronavirus les capacités de la ville ne
suffisent plus la maire-adjointe de la
capitale anastacia hirakova affirme que
les autorités sont obligées de mobiliser
de plus en plus de puteaux pour faire
face à la pandémie
d'abord nous avons réorienté nos
hôpitaux
dès que la première vague de la pandémie
s'est calmé nous avons commencé à
construire des hôpitaux de réserve les i
il est clair que maintenant quand nous
constatons une augmentation explosive
des cas de la maladie ses capacités ne
suffisent plus mais pour une courte
période j'espère vivement que ce n'est
que pour une courte période
nous mobilisons à nouveau d'autres
hôpitaux dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le virus i do nous savons qu'en
été le volume des autres soins médicaux
diminue légèrement
j'espère que dès que le taux de
contamination diminuera ses hôpitaux
retrouverons immédiatement leur
fonctionnement normal
mais nous garderons ses capacités de
réserve qui nous permettent de faire
face dans un premier temps à n'importe
quel taux de contamination
la directrice de l' agence fédérale
rospotrebnadzor anneaux popova explique
la situation actuelle par la propagation
du variante delta ii coronavirus selon
elle même si chaque nouvelle souche est
plus forte que la précédente
il s'agit toujours du même virus le
virus delta a touché jusqu'à 90 pays
aujourd'hui
il s'est rapidement propagé dans le
monde et il est en train de remplacer la
souche britannique mais il faut dire que
lorsque en décembre dernier la souche
britannique est apparue elle a
rapidement remplacer celle de one à
laquelle on était déjà habitué dans un
grand nombre de police maintenant la
nouvelle c'est le processus de
l'évolution du virus
bien sûr chaque nouvelle version
apparaît pour faire en sorte que la
mutation consolidé lui permettent de
2009 la population
chaque nouvelle souche est plus forte
que la précédente modifié de façon à ce
qu'elles touchent de plus en plus de
gens je les en même temps il s'agit
toujours du même virus
c'est largement plus de 23000 de
nouveaux cas de coronavirus ont été
détectés en russie en dernières 24
heures dont presque 7000 à moscow le
nombre des décès monté jusqu'à 679 dans
le pays
c'est le maximum depuis le début de la
pandémie et sur le continent africain le
nombre des cas augmente à un rythme
alarmant plus que la moitié d'entre eux
sont détectés en afrique du sud le pays
a enregistré en 24 heures dix neuf mille
500 nouveaux cas le plus lourd bilan
quotidien depuis mois de janvier la
campagne de vaccination se poursuit plus
de 3 millions de personnes on refuse
leur première dose à cet instant je suis
physiquement et émotionnellement fatigué
cette pandémie est particulièrement dur
[Musique]
mais nous n'avons jamais vu autant de
décès je pense que lorsqu'on est en
formation nous prépare à voir des gens
mourir mais c'est anormal de les voir
mourir à cette cadence avec le nouveau
variant la troisième vague et je pense
plus agressive que la seconde car nous
avons tendance à avoir des patients et
quand ils arrivent leur niveau d'oxygène
est déjà bas donc on pense que c'est
plus agressif que la seconde vague
plusieurs hauts responsables libanais
dans le viseur de la justice pour leur
rôle présumé dans l'explosion du port de
beyrouth c'était l'été dernier le juge
d'instruction en charge de l'enquêté va
auditionner le premier ministre
démissionnaire hassan diab
le magistrat a également adressé une
requête au parlement pour lever
l'immunité parlementaire de trois
députés qui ont occupé des postes de
ministres ils sont suspectées de
négligences qui ont conduit à l'accident
la gigantesque à déflagration a fait
plus de 200 morts et 6000 500 blessés
elle a été causée par l'accumulation
dans un entrepôt de nitrate d'ammonium
sont mesure de précaution autrefois
appelée la suisse du moyen-orient le
liban prix est aujourd'hui confronté un
violon un effondrement économique
aggravée par la corruption des élites
politiques le pays plonge dans la misère
et le désespoir
une situation jamais connu même pendant
la guerre civile de 75
un rapport de l'unicef est accablant
explication monaco dès lors le liban
continue sa descente aux enfers
les prix des denrées alimentaires et des
produits de première nécessité ont été
multipliées par cinq depuis 2019
les femmes sont notamment touchés par la
précarité monstre ul il se dit elle ne
peut plus acheter des serviettes
hygiéniques à ses filles alors c'est le
système d je prends des couches pour les
roannais à défaut temps je la mets comme
ça et je dis à ma fille d'utiliser ainsi
aux vôtres
ayant imaginé j'ai trois filles et les
trois ont leurs règles en même temps
comment je peux me procurer des salles
et hygiénique
surtout dans une telle situation début
juin un rapport de la banque mondiale a
classé la crise économique et financière
du liban parmi les trois épisodes de
crises les plus graves du monde depuis
le milieu du 19e siècle
le pays est sans gouvernement depuis 10
mois ou plus de 60% de la population est
passée sous le seuil de pauvreté selon
l'onu le chômage a atteint un chiffre
record 39% de la population
la monnaie du pays n'a pas été épargné
elle a perdu plus de 90% de sa valeur
face au dollar aujourd'hui que peut
espérer un pays sans vous
vernement difficile à dire la crise
économique et social a été aggravée par
la pandémie de coronavirus et l'
explosion dévastatrice au port de
beyrouth en août dernier le fonds
monétaire international a proposé son
aide
mais la classe politique du pays a été
incapable d'instaurer des réformes pour
sortir le pays du chaos
depuis le pays divague seule la
paupérisation a doublé passant de 28% de
la population en 2018 à 55 % en 2020 et
les enfants subissent cette crise de
plein fouet
selon le rapport de l'unicef plus de 30%
d'enfants se couchent avec le ventre
vide
certains enfants sont contraints
d'abandonner l'école c'est le cas de
quatre cent mille d'entre eux et un
enfant sur dix a été envoyée travailler
77% des ménages n'ont pas d'argent pour
s'acheter de la nourriture leur santé et
leur sécurité sont à risques et leur
avenir est mise en jeu
de plus en plus de familles sont
obligées de recourir à des mesures
d'adaptation négatives notamment en
sautant des repas en envoyant leurs
enfants travailler dans des conditions
souvent dangereuses ou en mariant leur
jeune fille et cette paupérisation
concerne également la classe moyenne qui
jusqu'à présent vivait décemment après
un petit sursaut inattendu
le parlement libanais a approuvé une
carte d'approvisionnement entre 90 et
130 $ qui sera accordé aux ménages les
plus pauvres
cinq cent mille familles devraient en
bénéficier mais les libanais n'attendent
plus rien de leur classe dirigeante en
2020 après la catastrophe du port ce qui
a été appelé l'initiative française est
aujourd'hui un flop en août 2020
emmanuel macron était alors apparu tel
un sauveur paradant dans les rudes un
beyrouth ravagé promettant d'aider le
pays à se libérer des griffes d'une
classe politique corrompue mais le
constat est amer
après quelques visites seulement des
sanctions sont tombées à l'égard des
figures politiques
rien d'exceptionnel selon un
éditorialiste du journal américain
foreign policy
le président français n'a pas tenu ses
engagements le problème principal était
que la réussite du plan français
reposait sur cette même classe politique
qui avait été dès le départ jugé
responsable des catastrophes à l'oeuvre
dans le pays
son refus d'engager des réformes est
sans doute la principale raison de
l'échec du plan français l'impasse
libanaise est en partie la faute de
macron la réticence de la france à
sanctionner sévèrement les élites
politiques en place pour se contenter de
les supplier de prendre des mesures et
est d'une naïveté confondante et a fini
par avoir des conséquences délétères
une étude publiée par informations
internationales estiment que la crise
économique à laquelle le liban est
confronté ferait grimper le taux de
chômage est 65 % de la population active
avant le 17 octobre et début du
soulèvement populaire on comptait 25 %
de chômeurs dans le pays
selon l'étude si aucune mesure d'urgence
n'est prise le liban pourrait compter un
million de chômeurs pour la première
fois de son histoire alors qu'il compte
six millions d'habitants et nous sommes
en direct de beyrouth avec un arthur
l'an dernier chef de mission pour sos
chrétiens d'orient bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur arte france
aujourd'hui à la pauvreté touche
l'ensemble de la population libanaise
bon sens madame louis c'est lui manque
c'est bien résumé la situation dans
votre reportage en fait c'est une
catastrophe économique sans nom c'est
une vraie descente aux enfers conte à
laquelle on est confronté au quotidien
ici au liban
c'est à dire que vraiment comme vous
avez expliqué c'est une des plus graves
crises économiques depuis la moitié du
19e siècle c'est quand même quelque
chose de d'inédits d'incroyable et qui
se voit au quotidien ici au liban est
pas qu à beyrouth en fait dans tout le
pays et cela touche toutes les
communautés présentes au liban c'est une
réelle catastrophe et ce qu'ils touchent
évidemment bien sûr toutes les tranches
de la population que ce soient les plus
jeunes ou les plus vieux comment est-ce
que la situation humanitaire a évolué
ces derniers mois eh bien écoutez elle a
voulu malheureusement dans le bon sens
on est vraiment face à une énorme crise
humanitaire c'est à dire que des enfants
par exemple ne peuvent plus rentrer à
l'école des familles vivent au quotidien
comme on a vu de votre reportage cette
femme qui ne peut plus acheter justement
les produits nécessaires pour ses filles
pour leur règle enfin je veux dire on
est on veut absolument plus se fournir
en biens de première nécessité
même les médicaments il ya une très une
énorme crise une pandémie ne par une
pénurie de médicaments au liban qui est
gravissime de même par exemple le simple
médicaments pour
la douleur on entre en plus on n'en
trouve plus et c'est une catastrophe
même des biens de première nécessité
mais pour se nourrir plus une famille
que nous rencontrons au quotidien avec
sos chrétiens d'orient ne peuvent plus
boucler les fins de mois
donc c'est une vraie catastrophe à
laquelle est confrontée la fameuse suite
du moyen-orient malheureusement la suite
du moyen-orient aujourd'hui bien au
travail des humanitaires comment est ce
que vous arrivez à aider les populations
qui font appel à rodez de différentes
manières mais comme vous avez parlé
également parlé on est on est l'accent
énormément sur la jeunesse en fait sur
les jeunes sur les enfants
malheureusement énormément d'écoles
risque de fermer à la rentrée faute de
moyens alors évidemment les écoles ans
elles subissent les différentes crises
qui sont en train d'avoir lieu au liban
il ya d'abord eu une explosion en fait
l'année dernière donc le 4e 2020 avec si
on détruit énormément d'établissements
ya à peu près cent vingt-huit
tablissements à beyrouth qui ont subi
des dommages à la suite de l'explosion
donc imaginez même d'un point de vue
psychologique pour les enfants de voir
en fait leurs classes détruites leur
verrou détruit de ne plus avoir la
possibilité de se rendre à l'école et
malheureusement avec la crise du dollar
c'est dire qu'il faut se rendre compte
que la valeur de la livre libanaise a
perdu 90% de sa valeur face au dollar
je veux dire si c'est une semaine
d'évaluation mais catastrophique ce qui
fait que les familles du couple ne
peuvent plus financer la scolarisation
des enfants
c'est pour ça qu'elle souhaite chrétiens
d'orient du coup on s'engage pour
justement alléger au maximum les buts et
des familles en finançant la
scolarisation des enfants et nous allons
également venir en aide à plus de 20
écoles au liban qui se retrouve cette
situation catastrophique comme je vous
ai dit je le répète 80% des
établissements catholiques risque de
fermer à la rentrée
qu'est-ce que de ne pas pouvoir ouvrir
sachant qu'il faut savoir que deux tiers
des enfants au liban qu'ils soient
musulmans chrétiens vont dans des écoles
catholiques
donc cela concerne vraiment toute la
population et on a vraiment très peur de
ce qui va se passer à la rentrée va
falloir absolument recevoir de l'aide
pour assurer une scolarité décente à
tous les enfants libres vous portez sur
la communauté
international qui conditionne son aide
au lancement de réformes contre la
corruption et clientélisme au liban
écoutez il serait tendre il serait temps
malheureusement le liban aujourd'hui
subi en fait les choix politiques et les
acteurs politiques de ces quarante
dernières années
il faut pas regarder uniquement ces
quatre cinq dernières années mais il
faut voir la chose dans sa globalité et
malheureusement oui nous sommes
confrontés une classe politique qui
donne l'impression en tout cas d'avoir
en fait abandonner le pape d'avoir en
fait tout simplement eu envie de tout
simplement plus répondre aux attentes du
peuple
et d'ailleurs et comme vous l'avez dit
ça fait dix mois qu'on n'a pas de
gouvernement les libanais craque
complètement et on se rend compte qu'il
y en a la plus grave crise de l'histoire
de liban et on n'a même pas un
gouvernement à la tête du pays pour
pouvoir répondre à l'urgence qui est à
l'urgence humanitaire à l'urgence
économique à l'enfance sociétale à
l'urgence de l'éducation des enfants
on a l'impression que le bateau
malheureusement nos bateaux le liban est
un bateau qui part à la dérive
il n'y a plus de capitaine et personne
n'est capable justement de prendre les
prendre en main le pays pour apporter
enfin une réponse à l'urgence qui a lieu
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir sur notre antenne arthur
longtemps je rappelle que vous êtes chef
de mission au liban pour sos chrétiens
d'orient le retrait américain
d'afghanistan ne sera pas conclue dans
les prochains jours c'est ce qu'a assuré
joe biden avant que la maison blanche ne
déclare qu'il sera achevé fin août
annonce faite alors que les troupes
américaines et de l'otan viennent tout
juste de quitter la base aérienne de
bagram la plus grande du pays
une étape symbolique qu'elle est et le
centre des opérations américaines durant
la guerre déclenchée en 2001 elle a été
restituée à l'armée afghane
les talibans s'en sont réjouis la
population elle s'inquiète du départ des
forces étrangères
les etats-unis qui avaient indiqué que
leurs derniers soldats quitteraient
l'afghanistan d'ici 11 septembre l'armée
régulière elle sera alors seul face aux
talibans et à leurs alliés
de quoi ouvrir une période d'incertitude
la situation en afghanistan va se
détériorer
la situation est déjà chaotique il peut
voir le district de ghorband en train de
tomber en ruine
il y a beaucoup d'insécurité
le gouvernement ne dispose pas de toutes
les armes et de tous les équipements la
base aérienne de bagram sera pire si
quelqu'un me laisse faire je l'appuierai
aussi nous sommes ni heureux ni
contrarié par leur retrait d'afghanistan
nous avions une vie paisible lorsque les
américains étaient là ça fait un an
qu'ils ont détruit toute cette zone est
ciac c'était le mur de l'aérodrome de
vaincre âme depuis qu'ils ont commencé
le retrait la situation a empiré
il n'y a pas de travail pas d'emploi pas
de commerce pour les gens étaient prêtes
à faire face seules aux talibans nous
avons posé la question à jaar vespière
fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté
elle est prête dans la mesure où elle
est organisée elle est armée mais à les
talibans une tactique n'est ce pas de
guerre asymétrique
donc voilà une armée régulière n'est pas
forcément prêt america face à cela et
c'est vraiment une difficulté qui se
profile et donc les américains à les
états unis ont pris des décisions de
garder une présence militaire autour de
l'afghanistan
donc soit par l'intermédiaire de leurs
offres flotte dans l'océan indien est
aussi dans des pays de proximité à le
secrétaire d'état à la défense des états
unis a échangé pas plus tard qu'hier
avec le ministre des affaires étrangères
d'ouzbékistan quitte un des trois pays
proches donc frontière commune de
l'afghanistan au nord
un retour en france décisions prises la
chapelle darblay le groupe upm
propriétaire de la papeterie a tranché
en faveur d'une offre de reprise qui
transformera le site en une unité de
production d'hydrogène l'usiné pourtant
la dernière en france à fabriquer du
papier recyclé depuis la fermeture
de leur usine il ya plus d'un an les
syndicats se battent pour obtenir un
moratoire afin de préserver leur savoir
faire
reportage décèle farge et renault
parquet tous ensemble déterminé à ne
rien lâcher
le cso extraordinaire de ce matin auquel
ont assisté les délégués syndicaux de la
cgt a laissé de nombreuses questions en
suspens quant à l'avenir de la papeterie
l'offre de reprise qui a été acceptée
par upm le groupe finlandais
propriétaire du site
aucun ici ne la comprend et prévoit un
démantèlement du site qui est unique en
france pour à la place et installer une
unité de production d'hydrogène pour les
syndicats impossible de laisser passer
ça d'autant que grâce à leur
mobilisation
une offre pape et yelle est sur la table
mais pour qu'elle aboutisse
ils ont besoin de temps on a demandé à
l'état à bercy au ministère de
l'industrie et autres de jouer leur rôle
de prendre publiquement une position sur
chapelle darblay de faciliter le point
de position oui et de faciliter une
industrie pts à petit un redémarrage
industriel peut-il sur chapelle darblay
notre accord est tombé le 30 juin 2021
pardon les positions les salariés et
syndicats ont réussi à mobiliser de
nombreux acteurs dans leur lutte
philippe martinez secrétaire général de
la cgt la mère de grand-couronne
plusieurs ong comme greenpeace ou encore
le président du ceser le conseil
économique social et environnemental
régional
pour ce dernier le projet hydrogène n'a
rien à faire sur ce site
le ceser après position en faveur
suite à une sollicitation d'ailleurs des
représentants du personnel de chapelle
darblay position pour que cette
entreprise soit reprise mais dans le
cadre de la filière peu
et singulièrement avec ses spécificités
de traitement et valorisation des
déchets papiers cartons l'offre papier
remis sur la table par les syndicats et
vitré non seulement un démantèlement du
site mais permettrait surtout de
conserver un savoir faire unique en
france de saut vers en somme toute une
économie circulaire pour les syndicats
et représentants cadre ce qu'il manque
c'est une réelle prise de position de la
part des pouvoirs publics
mais qu'est ce qui bloque c'est la
volonté de porter un projet papier on
nous a toujours on l'est toujours
d'ailleurs
cantonné dans cette offre papetière mais
qui est parti ailleurs finalement en ne
portant aucun crédit à d'autres à
d'autres projets
sauf que cet homme papetière elle est
partie elle et elle est partie sans ses
partenaires les partenaires qui se sont
trouvés plantés ont décidé de revenir
avec nous depuis le 30 juin dernier le
démantèlement du site peut donc arriver
à tout moment
de leur côté les salariés et syndicats
comptent plus que jamais sur l'état et
ce à la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain journal dans une
trentaine de minutes au total
[Musique]
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une importante compagnie de
taxis en france l'activité a repris sda
actuellement dans paris ou pas les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour il avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de touristes
étrangers